[Applause]
welcome back everybody I'm here with
Kayla Reese give it
up so it is the countdown to the Paris
Olympics and my next guest is one of the
most anticipated athletes to watch she
is a two-time Olympic gold medalist and
current world record holder in the 400
meter hurdles despite her success though
she has struggled with anxiety and
insecurity something she writes about in
her new book Far Beyond gold running
from Fear to Faith everybody please
welcome Sydney mlac
[Music]
Leon hello meet Kay meet another
exceptional athlete and then meet
another exceptional kid amazing this I
was saying this show is making me
inferior as a human I was like wow
everybody athletic today uh we need to
set this up so Sydney is the first woman
to break 52 seconds in the 400 meter
hurdle she is also the first to break 51
seconds in fact of this is crazy of the
10 fastest times in history history
Sydney holds six of those
records your your dog
like that's incredible I would feel like
Captain Marvel like yeah I would do you
feel good about going into the Olympics
you feel good about do I listen the
competition is insane every year so you
always have to respect your competitors
obviously feeling good but the target is
always on my back so yeah just getting
prepared for that do you though cuz I I
nothing like you but I did grow up in
sports and I was I loved that the coach
was always like compete against yourself
in your best time like absolutely so do
you think about that more so like I mean
I try to run my own race worry about my
10 hurdles worry about my lane and yeah
you can't get focused on what everyone
else is doing because everyone has a
different process and so for me every
day it's how can I beat myself yeah um
so was Olympic boxing is that ever a
dream it still can be you do all the
things well fun fact I know fun fact um
women's boxing wasn't in the Olympics
until 2012 so I went pro in 2008 and
there was no there was no uh Avenue for
that there was no Avenue so I could do
all the amateur tournaments but
financially I couldn't make them so I
just decided to go pro the day after I
decided to go pro I heard they were put
in boxing the Olympics but everything
happens for a reason and um I'm glad
they have it now because there's so many
opportunities and I see so many young
women coming up in the amateur ranks and
getting so much experience so I didn't
know that you were giving me all the
information for more you know um well I
heard this about you too you juggle
before meets is this true I do I is this
like like a meditation thing like
therapeutic thing yeah juggling is
actually really good number one for like
calming you down it gives you something
else to focus on it's really good for
hand eye coordination um and it's a
really good party trick that you can
just pull out anywhere so yeah yeah I
mean that's an amazingly random thing
but I love that everybody has their
thing did you ever have anything you'd
have to do like to settle yourself
before going in the ring I like kind of
like calm funny chill vibe in the back
um but like I bring my ceremonial ways I
guess you could say into the ring it's I
usually have traditional dancers in and
drummers bring me out to the ring it's
an honor to my Heritage and kind of just
that Collective energy to put that
healing Vibes out so but and it's and
it's it is kind of a cool cool yeah oh
it's very cool um writing a book I can't
imagine like I not into the idea
personally um but it's but because it
has to be hard and vulnerable like what
what do you think was the most
challenging part writing the book man uh
I mean the point of the book I've
struggled with fear my whole life uh
kind of just my identity in being a
winner and obviously that's not
guaranteed in this life and and I think
I'm very grateful to God for setting me
free from that by way of Jesus Christ
and my goal with the book was really
just to encourage readers to to seek Him
and seek that freedom that is far beyond
gold um and the hardest part I would say
is just being honest with my past and my
own insecurities and things that I maybe
didn't do right but being able to own
that and show that with Christ we are
forgiven from those things it is a lot
of weight to put on a 17-year-old kid
you know you're saying you're 17 years
old and like I can't even IM imagine
like even the hormones that are
happening at 7 you know what I'm saying
and then also trying to do something so
huge and so much pressure that's a lot
absolutely yeah keep juggling keep
juggling yeah that's what I say um
Sydney I can't wait to juggle at lunch
just to see if I can do it uh Sydney's
book Far Beyond gold running from Fear
to Faith is available right now
everybody be sure to pick up a copy and
you can cheer for Sydney and Team USA
this summer watch the Paris Olympics on
NBC and talk we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home